[BASKETBALLS DRIBBLING]
Yeah, boys!
A place that I
always have enjoyed
is the Lavietes
Pavilion for basketball.
My husband is a
particular basketball fan,
and I have taken up his
attitude towards basketball.
And so from the beginning
of my presidency--
and really even before, when
I was the Radcliffe dean--
we have been
attendees at Lavietes.
I remember, very soon
after I became president,
attending a women's basketball
game and celebrating with them
my ascension to female power
as the newly-named president.
We also had the privilege of
watching a remarkable player,
who just was a total standout on
the Harvard team at that time,
named [? Jeremy ?] [? Lin, ?]
who has since become
a superstar with the advent of
[? "Linsanity" ?] when he broke
out as a really wonderfully
effective player in the NBA
soon after his beginning
of his professional career.
I now have the great joy of
seeing a renovated Lavietes--
updated, lightened, with
better seating, a jumbotron
to show videos, with
just a better scoreboard.
Just a much better place
for players and spectators,
with, also, better locker rooms
and backstage elements as well.
So it's fun to be
in the same place
and have it look a lot the
same, but also different
in ways that sustain
tradition but make it
a much better place for our
wonderful basketball teams
to play.
[CHATTER, BASKETBALL DRIBBLING]